[Music]
so today's cancellation is something of
a layup i suppose here's here's a just a
thing that's begging to be canceled seth
rogen and sarah silverman are starring
in an animated christmas themed
miniseries called santa inc
which was just released today on hbo max
um
i i will play some of the preview for
you but you probably don't need to see
it because all you have to do is imagine
in your head
what a woke animated r-rated christmas
show starring seth rogen and sarah
silverman might look and sound like
and what you're imagining in your head
is exactly what hbo has provided us
uh now that you've already imagined it
and i played it it'll be it'll feel a
little bit like deja vu i suppose but
but here it is
when you're a kid there's only one day a
year more special than any other day
and that day is christmas
and we are the magic behind that day
so let's get these [ __ ] kids some
[ __ ] presents
may i present the hardest working man in
snow biz good golly he's jolly our own
santa claus
hey merry christmas whoa
you're on my naughty list
[Music]
good news sir more american kids believe
in you than they do in vaccines or the
holocaust that's great i mean
disheartening for america but great for
us
i'm here from the north pole times have
you decided who will succeed you with
santa claus subtext santa's old and
knocking on death's door
uh i mean uh that good question i'll
give it some serious thought
bye
there have been many santa clauses
throughout history some were loved
others loathed but the position of santa
has mostly been a white man's game
exactly it's [ __ ] crazy things have
got to change my advice to you is
if i die get rid of my porn
i want to be the next santa if this is
your dream you have to at least make
your case
you gotta get intimate with that jolly
that was without exaggeration one of the
worst previews i've ever seen in my life
for anything ever
and i didn't even play the worst parts
because there's another 45 seconds or so
where we learn more about how santa is
bad because he's white and male
and what we really need is a non-white
non-male santa also a non-christian
santa would seem
it it probably didn't escape your notice
that the lead actors in this christmas
show
are not christian
now that wouldn't be a problem except
that the show is making fun of christmas
and um was obviously produced by people
who have real animosity towards
christmas traditions
one can only imagine the response if
christian actors start in a film making
fun of islamic customs for example
in fact even if christian actors started
a film paying tribute to islam
and saying nice things about it
it would still be considered offensive
and appropriative
and yet non-christian actors can star in
films mocking christmas and that's
perfectly acceptable
but that's far from the worst part
this has been a big week for me
personally i've added um a number of
uh if important titles onto my name
including best-selling children's author
but the other one is lord so i'm really
lord best-selling children's author matt
walsh now um i am officially a lord
through established titles established
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady and gain the
respect that you so
desperately deserve all you need is one
square foot plot of land in scotland
that's all it takes
so it's a little bit of a loophole we're
exploiting here and i love it
established titles is a project based on
a historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you'll receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land if you ever in
scotland you can go out and check it out
as well with with this certificate you
could officially change your name to
lord or lady and get it on your credit
card your plane tickets etc establish
titles is having a great limited time
sale so go to establishtitles.com matt
walsh to save 10 off today and remember
to use the discount code matt walsh or
just click the link below that's
dot com slash matt walsh or click the
link below what we really see is why and
how
comedy has died in our country
now i i personally can forgive almost
any sin that comedy commits as long as
it's still funny
that that's my position the the the the
job of comedy is to be funny after all
and so i'm somewhat of a machiavellian
ends justify the means type when it
comes to comedy as long as you're making
me laugh
i'm not all that worried about how you
do it because i figure that's the job
here that's what you're supposed to be
doing just make your comedy funny and
that's all i ask we'll sort the other
details out later
and yet this this fundamental
requirement is too onerous for most
comedies these days in this show it
seems that most of the laughs are
supposed to come from the fact that the
characters are cursing
the show is very impressed with its own
vulgarity
it so it's vulgar just for the sake of
being vulgar the very first punch line
is that an elf says the f word that's
like the only punchline in the whole
previews that all the characters oh
they're they're cussing and they're
cartoons
and they go back to that well time and
again look an elf is cussing look now
santa is cussing look now reindeer is
cussing
just wait till you hear the first uh you
hear frosty the snowman he's going to
cuss too
it's lazy and it's boring it's childish
comedies these days are often lazy
boring and childish also we have the
woke factor of course
and woke isn't funny because for one
thing there's nothing amusing about
being preached at in a certain context
it might be kind of funny to watch a
feminist screech about the patriarchy or
whatever i mean i was amused by the
feminists protesting my event last night
and screeching at me but that's not the
kind of amusement you want to derive
from a comedy
and most importantly on top of being
irritating and self-righteous and
fundamentally humorous
woke also represents the mainstream
position
the position held by the powerful and
the elite
comedy especially a vulgar r-rated
comedy should be transgressive and edgy
it should challenge the mainstream
perspective
it should desecrate the sacred cows
comedy when it comes
when it performs this task
is actually playing an important role in
society i think but most comedy today is
propaganda on behalf
of the elites of the ruling class
that's why when i watch snl for like the
90 seconds i can stomach it every six
months or so
i get the sense that i'm watching
like sketch comedy in north korea or
something it's probably very similar
there
propaganda with bad punch lines and
forced laughter and finally this show
like so much comedy today
um isn't funny because it's too angry to
be funny
it's it's resentful
it's perfectly possible to make a
christmas comedy that pokes fun at
christmas traditions
and also manages to be very funny
many such comedies exist a christmas
story is an all-time classic in that
genre
but that requires you to have some kind
of understanding of
and affection for the thing that you're
lampooning if you hate it
then all you'll end up making is a
disgruntled diatribe not a comedy
and that's what this is
that's why everybody associated with
this crime against comedy and against
humanity
is of course today cancelled
and those of you who have not gone to
uh dailywire.com and uh or rather
johnnywalrus.com it's a quickest way to
get there those of you have not gone to
johnnyvalvers.com and purchased the book
johnny walrus you are also cancer
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated